je félicite chacun d'entre vous d'avoir
gagné le concours et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue sur l'île et tout fantasme
c'est quoi les l'exos chaque souhait
selon la fantaisie des clients votre vie
est sur le point de changer pour
toujours
j'espère que vous a appris comment lille
arrive à faire tout ça c'est un mystère
j'appellerai alors c'est quoi ton soit
le venger d'une fille qui me torturaient
l'école la plus populaire de l'école a
décidé que je serais ses victimes
on va rigoler un peu mais je rêve c'est
vraiment un
parce que je voulais dire des formes ce
qu'on m'a demandé où ils ont fait venir
pour accomplir votre chance une fois que
l' aventure a commencé vous devez aller
jusqu'au bout j'aurais pas cru que
c'était possible